what
[Music]
no laughter cycle you asked to cycle I
didn't know you had a bike I had a
mohawk there's a lot about me you don't
know yeah Mohawk you didn't miss
anything
yeah this one's electric what's that
mean means it's good you will be great I
will be great and you will do we will
both be great
[Music]
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them all vegetables wanted all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant moms new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right he'll be bring supers back into
the sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I'll watch the kids no problem do it
dad they wants to do it I don't know
that way why would they change math hey
honey everything's great
he's in excellent health that is freaky
you know it's crazy right to help my
family I gotta leave it to fix the law I
gotta break it you've got to destroy
kids can have that choice thank you
young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen slacker interrupts this
program for an important announcer it
might get weird I'll be there
[Music]